[Applaudissements]
vous avez un discours élaborés face à mu
ce que vous aurez pu lui dire tout
simplement que tu l'as vu mon q est ce
que c'est la france est elle assez
perfectible
je vais jouer beaucoup m'engage vous
parlez des gages que vous avez moi c'est
un gage exhorté sorte que ça marche il
faut dire tu l'as vu la police à coup de
pouce car il a compris c'est très visuel
c'est un truc ça ça vous fout en l'air
toute ambiance les gens sont tendus
j'ai réussi à l'avoir parce que je vais
demander comment disait ici en espagnol
et marina qui disait ça fait en sorte un
peu ces vagues
gérard jugnot qui est quand même qui
explique les règles du sud a finalement
eu ni vol sale affaire moment de télé
quand même ça au plus haut point je
pense que c'est la mère de teuphu